este ataque masivo de drones kamikazes
sobre kiev comenzó alrededor de las dos
de la madrugada y continúa así durante
varias horas cuando ya había salido el
sol Esto fue un ataque según las
autoridades el más grande que se ha dado
con este tipo de drones kamikazzi desde
el comienzo de la invasión a gran escala
y hay que recordar que en los últimos
semanas desde que comenzó el mes de mayo
estos ataques se han hecho aún mayores
Ese es el número 14 desde que comenzó el
mes pero el de ayer el día de esta
madrugada era el más grande de todos
fueron 40 drones lanzados sobre la
ciudad 54 en total en el país 52 fueron
interceptados pero aún así hubo daños en
kiev algunos de los restos o que de los
drones cayeron en algunos edificios
causando fuego y también una persona
murió y otra quedó herida cuando uno de
estos restos de los También cayó en una
bomba de gasolina al sur de la Ciudad
Hoy es un día especial para la ciudad
porque es el Día de kiev El último
domingo de mayo y obviamente no hay
grandes celebraciones como consecuencia
de la guerra pero estamos en primavera
hace buen tiempo y la gente sale a la
calle a los parques y alrededor del río
nosotros en este momento estamos afuera
de la ciudad pero estuvimos allí durante
la madrugada y entendimos realmente la
crudeza con la que fue atacada y
realmente cómo tuvo que ponerse a prueba
el sistema de defensa antiaéreo de la